هذا وكان منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي قال
للجزيره ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل دعم
القوه الاوكرانيه ميدانيا واكد ان
الرئيسكي وحده من يختاروا توقيت التفاوضى
مع روسيا
يمكن ان يعرف متى ستنتهي ما يمكن التحدث
به على وجه اليقين هو اننا سنستمر في دعم
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في الميدان حتى
تتمكن من الاستمرار في تحقيق المزيد من
النجاح
الرئيسكي وحده من يحدد متى يكون مستعدا
لجلوس والتفاوض مع الروس بشروطه وبطريقه
التي يختارها
ينضم الينا من لندن كير جينز كبير محللي
شؤون روسيا واوروسيا في معهد شتم هاوس
اهلا بك سيد جايلز باعتقادك ما السبب
الرئيسي او مضمون هذا اللقاء الاول بين
رئيس الاستخبارات في البلدين من الانطلاق
الحرب في اوكرانيا
واخبار بان محتوى هذا اللقاء هو حول
الاسلحه النوويه وتستجابه للتهديدات التي
اطلقها الرئيس
ان هذا هو الموضوع الوحيد ولكن كده
الطرفين سلطات الضوء على اهميته لماذا
الاهلي ان كان هذا هو الملف ال- ال-
الاكثر ترجيحا في ما يتعلق باستعمال
الاسلحه النوويه
هذا صحيح اذا
الحيه بتحدث عن موضوع الاسلحه النوويه قد
يظن البعض انها قد مرتا لان هذه التهديدات
لم تؤخذ على محمل الجد وتم تجاهل هذه
التهديدات ولكن في الحقيقه تبرز الحاجه
لكل الطرفين قال الولايات المتحده وروسيا
لتامين الاستقرار الاستراتيجي اي التحدث
بكل ما يحصل بخصوص النزاع في اوكرانيا
وليست بالضروره ان يكون مرتبطا بشكل مباشر
بهذا النزاع من غير المرجح ان يكون هناك
رسائل حول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حول
موقف اوكرانيا من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن يجب ان لا نستثني امكانيه
التمرير الرسائل عبر الولايات المتحده من
كيف الى روسيا ماذا عما يتم تسريبه او
اعلان هو من قبل وسائل الاعلام عن ضغوط
امريكيه على كليب من اجل التوجه للتفاوض
تم تسليط الضوء عليه بشكل مستمر في خلال
هذا النزاع ولا يفاجئنا هناك
اعتقاد بان التوصل الى حل التفاوضى هو
الطريق الوحيده لوضعي حدد لهذه الحرب ولكن
هذه الدعوات خفت بالبقره مع مكان عليه
الوضع في خلال فصل الصيف كان هناك مخاوف
بان اوكرانيا سوف تخسر هذه الحرب وان
الحرب سوف تستمر الى ما لا نهايه هذه
المخاوف تبددت لان اوكرانيا اثبتت ان
باستطاعتها ان تضغط على القوات الروسيه
وتؤدي الى انسحاب القوات الروسيه وهذا غير
اطار الحوار ولكن في خلفيت هذا الحوار
هناك قرار بانه في مرحله معينه يتعين على
روسيا واوكرانيا ان تتفاضه من لندن كبير
روسيا في معاه حادثه هاوس شكرا جزيلا